this isn't just any other holiday season
this year with the right gadget gifts
you can open the future in case you were
wondering eggnog in the future tastes
terrible
are you sure that isn't Soylent oh yeah
you're right
but you know what because awesome
definitely not Christmas sweaters hey
speak for yourself
actually what's really awesome is that
in 2016 some futuristic gadgets actually
got good that is awesome and that's why
we've picked out the tech that we would
buy for ourselves and in some cases
already have Amazon's echo and echo dot
have come closer than ever before to
giving us an artificially intelligent
assistant these talking speakers have a
built-in assistant named Alexa just say
Alexa play some holiday songs and she'll
bring up a playlist she can also tell
you the weather set cooking timers and
answer random questions Alexa one
Christmas Christmas Day will be on
Sunday December 25th 2016 which
PlayStation VR you no longer have to own
a mansion or a clunky PC play who makes
you look ridiculous I think I look like
a character from Tron psvr
is the best way to bring home virtual
reality right now because it just plugs
into the ps4 that's already in over 40
million home it also makes VRS social
experience by allowing everyone else in
the room walk along on the TV really a
router and for $350 yes really
the Eero Wi-Fi system is the best way to
bring your house into the future the
system allows you to place different
access points around your house leaving
Wi-Fi dead zones way in the past it may
be pricey but it's easy to set up and
work so well we both got them this year
speaking of wireless these Bose juicy 35
are the ticket to joining the wireless
revolution these bluetooth headphones
are not only tangle free but our tests
found they do by far the best job at
canceling noise on planes trains and
other annoying places on
fortunately even the best active noise
cancellation can't help you escape
careless you can't have the future
without your own robotic sidekick like
the antique Cosmo Cosmo uses cameras
sensors and AI to interact with pets and
humans
you can even program it to recognize
familiar faces and say hi and if you
ignore him he uses the world's tiniest
forklift to play with blocks on his own
and if you're looking for the ultimate
grown-up two-way there's finally a drone
I can recommend DJI Matic pro this 4k
camera takes amazing aerial shots and
has the very latest tech to help amateur
pilots like you and me avoid flying into
trees but what's amazing is that it
packs into this audible shape that's
small enough to fit into a small
backpack or a big pocket we have lots
more pics in our full gift guide at
wsj.com happy living in the future hello
we're still in here someone at least get
us a latke